you know sometimes I feel like the Joker
to Hollywood's Batman I have a feeling
you and I are destined to do this
forever
I said the last couple times I had
tackled LGBTQ related issues on this
channel that I was gonna try and do so
on a monthly basis I don't know if I
mentioned it specifically but I am gonna
make exceptions for news items that crop
up that kind of fall under that domain
when it comes to lbgtq plus
representation in entertainment and
media and a news story has most
definitely broken and I most definitely
have things to say about it which does
mean we're gonna swap this look out so
in case anyone needs the reminder of the
my dog in this race my name is Nathaniel
I have a fluid sense of gender and while
I do not normally use the term trans
subscribe myself because most folks who
use that term mean they are
transitioning or hope to transition
fully from the gender they were assigned
at birth to the one that they indeed are
that is not the case for me my sense of
gender wavers back and forth but I am
still a form of transgender I do not
always identify with the gender I was
assigned at birth so I'm gonna be
touching on a topic that I was planning
to talk about eventually but wasn't
planning to do for a while and I still
may end up talking about because I'm
gonna be talking about the specific
thing in terms of the news that broke
but ultimately what I wanted to do with
sort of a focus piece on it was do a lot
more research basically but I'm not
gonna wait to do that to talk about this
so if you hadn't heard Scarlett
Johansson was cast in an upcoming film
there was a little bit of a minor
bidding war this isn't you know a
massive blockbuster film but this looks
to be a planned prestige film and it's a
full film that will be called
rub-and-tug
it is inspired by the real-life story of
a figure from 1970s and 80s Pittsburgh
who went by the name Dante Tex Gill and
this individual ran a string of places
of prostitution under the cover of being
massage parlors and again it's a true
story this individual is deceased passed
away in 2003 and was born Jean Marie
Gill there does not appear to be
confirmed record of actual sex
reassignment surgery but the accounts of
all the people of people who knew this
individual say that she wish to be
called mr. Gill so she is the wrong term
he is the correct term he is the pronoun
that should be used because this was a
trans man and Scarlett Johansson will be
playing him in a film directed by Rupert
Sanders so the casting of cisgender
actors and actresses to play transgender
parts is by no means a new thing however
it is something that is starting to get
a spotlight Sean on it and people going
wait why are we doing that which is what
should happen now before I get too much
further I want to acknowledge that there
is a justification that can and probably
has been given by some for why a
cisgender actor would be playing a
chance transgender part depending on the
point in the individuals life that the
story takes place if it takes place
partly or even primarily before the
transition they may have appeared more
as
they were assigned at birth if it is in
some manner a period piece set at a time
before the current era of sexual
reassignment surgeries and hormone
replacement therapies then they may not
have been able to achieve a properly
masculine or feminine appearance that
would have been to their liking that
comes up in you know we start talking
about things like the Danish girl Albert
Nobbs breakfast on Pluto etc so I want
to acknowledge that there is a rationale
that can be given for why cisgender
performers are frequently cast in
transgender roles however it is a
rationale it is an explanation is it is
an excuse that I am no longer going to
accept if someone were to say to try and
use these cues well there aren't enough
trans actors and actresses I don't know
if anyone is making that issues but just
in case anyone claiming that isn't
looking I personally know trans women
and trans men who are actors I know very
well a trans man who I saw in a play
last month and I live in Vermont so you
cannot tell me that there are no
transgender people trying to make it as
actors in Hollywood so that's just wrong
people may claim that there are no trans
actors certainly no trans men actors who
have the sufficient name recognition to
get the project funded and that is true
but is also part of the problem because
of course there aren't because you won't
cast them in anything how are they ever
going to build a reputation well you'll
even allow them to play themselves if
you won't cast them in the first place
it's a similar argument that I actually
saw get circulated with ghost in the
shell which yeah I'll be bringing that
up and
back to it that there wasn't a Asian or
Asian American actress of appropriate
age with sufficient box-office clout for
a film as expensive as that was going to
be and whether or not that was true was
debatable but it illustrates the problem
because you're saying you won't cast
people because they aren't names but
they're not names because you won't cast
them so that's an excuse that I'm not
accepting anymore there is there is the
simple fact that in these various
projects the SIS performers who are cast
as trans people there is always some
degree of transformation applied to them
some degree of makeup or prosthetics
used to make this women appear or
masculine to make this man appeal or
more feminine why can we not do the
opposite why can we not take a trans man
actor and use that same makeup and
prosthetics to make them appear more
feminine if the story calls for that and
that's setting aside the fact that I
don't know if people not if you don't
have a ton of familiarity with the trans
community even realize this not all
transgender people pass as the gender
they identify as even some who have had
full sex-reassignment surgery and years
of hormone replacement therapy many do
not pass out a look as appearing to have
been born as the gender they identify as
so you can't really use that excuse
either however this particular instance
is more than just another example of an
ongoing issue because of the people
involved
I mentioned ghost in the shell' already
ghost in the shell' the live-action
version was the center of more than a
little bit of controversy over the
casting of Scarlett
Hansen in the lead role a role of major
Motoko Kusanagi a role written as a
Japanese character and I don't want to
rehash that specific argument because
regardless of whether or not you feel
that that was a choice that was
justified or if you think that was
completely wrong regardless there was an
uproar and it may have even hurt the
box-office because that movie did not do
well so to see not only Scarlett
Johansson
but the director of that film Rupert
Sanders same director and director from
ghost in the shell' the director on this
new project the same performer director
pair from that controversy casting a
cisgender performer as a trans person
not even trans character real-life trans
person the lack of self-awareness is
astounding and Scarlett Johansson has
actually responded to this through a
representative her representative
supposedly speaking on her behalf with
her words said and I'm going to quote
because when I get angry about these
things I want to get angry over people's
exact words and not what was reported as
the gist of it in response to the
casting and the initial pushback
Scarlett Johansson via a representative
told bustled that any questions quote
can be directed to Jeffrey Tambor Jared
Leto and Felicity Huffman 's reps for
comment in some context in case you
don't know what she actually meant by
that
jared leto won an Academy Award for
playing a trans woman in Texas buyers
club a movie I have not seen Felicity
Huffman was nominated for an Academy
Award for playing a trans woman in
Transamerica a film I have not seen
Jeffrey Tambor played the lead role in
the Amazon Prime television so
transparent which I have not seen or he
did until recently when he was fired for
harassing a transgender member of the
production crew so citing him at all huh
a little bit in bad taste but even
setting that aside
you can't just sight how something that
is not okay was not made it as big a
deal of publicly before as an excuse for
to keep doing it people getting away
with something that is wrong up to this
point is not a reason to keep doing it
at least in the instances of those
because even transparent which feels
very recent it's what going into his
fifth season years in there is an
argument to be made I don't know if I'd
buy it but there was an argument to be
made that in those instances and some of
the other ones I've cited that not as
many people knew better more people
should know better now and again you
can't just cite precedent of people
being allowed to do something that
you're getting called out on that
doesn't suddenly make it okay they got
away with it I'm sorry if you feel it's
unfair that you're not going to get away
with it but it wasn't okay then it's not
okay now I'm sorry that you feel
persecuted by that but this is the
reality all right
if a white actor was cast to play a
black role in blackface not as an ironic
commentary on anything just to pull just
so they could play a black person and if
that actor or director or studio or
anyone tried to excuse that as being
okay by citing that it was okay when Al
Jolson did it in the jazz singer they
would rightfully be called out on that
as spouting utter [ __ ] which is what
this is I like you very much Scarlett
Johansson you are a very talented
actress but this is bull you cannot take
away our stories we have stories to be
told what little I could find out about
this person about this man about Dante
tech skill is fascinating and could make
for an amazing movie and a movie worth
telling but you can't take our stories
to tell them for us when we're not
asking you to and think that that's ok
if you want to help us tell our stories
because to be blunt about it you have
resources we don't most of us if you
want to help us tell our stories that
would be amazing
but you can't take our stories from us
exclude us from the process and then
just tell those stories on our behalf
it's not o.k and if you want to tell me
that the only way that this film could
be financed is with someone like
scarlett johansson's name on it fine but
don't have her play the trans man part
again
very preliminary research that I did
into this individual he had a girlfriend
who was central to us like half Scarlett
Johansson play her and then find a
talented trans man actor cuz I know they
exist I've met them and I'm not even at
Hollywood and let us be involved in the
telling of our stories this as I said
the overall premise and the overall
topic of cisgender performers playing
transgender characters is something I am
gonna revisit because III want to do
something more focused more researched
more coherent possibly then this video
is going to end up being but I couldn't
wait to do that background research to
talk about this now
and I as a general rule make a very
strong point of not wishing ill on
anyone it's something that I implore for
my commenters and it's the kind of stuff
I have to delete from the comments
section most frequently our personal
attacks so I won't do that I won't
attack the individuals involved I will
say that some of them absolutely should
know better but I'm not going to wish
ill on them I am however going to hope
for the failure of this project I hope
that the pushback is so harsh that the
financier is that New Regency of the
studio that picked it up gets cold feet
and drops the project and that in this
form it collapses
I don't want to see a trans story that
does not involve a trans performer I
don't I just don't anymore
and that's not to say that there have
been instances of a quote unquote being
done well as I said most of the things I
cited I haven't seen they're frankly not
my type of movies they may have been
done well I'm not saying they're bad
films but I'm not going to say that oh
it's okay cuz it's been okay it wasn't
okay then it's really not okay now and
before anyone tries to say to me you
know they're actors they're supposed to
be able to play things other than
themselves
you know there are times that gay
performers play straight straight
performers play gay performers all the
time perform as you know people of a
certain religion that they themselves
are art with a family history in a
background that they don't have why is
this different and all things being
equal it wouldn't be but that's the
thing all things aren't equal when a
cisgender person is cast to tell the
story of a transgender person not only
are they taking our stories away from us
they are depriving struggling talented
transgender performers from work so
until we are in such a state as
transgender performers are regularly
cast in cisgender roles this will not be
okay if and when we ever live in that
world then by all means then you can
have your cisgender performers in your
transgender roles that is absolutely not
the world we live in right now and the
world we live in right now
I'm not okay with this and I won't be
okay with this and I hope that every
instance and attempt at doing this gets
pushed back gets backlash and fails
ideally fails to even finish being made
short of that fails at the box office
even if it's a good movie
I don't care stop excluding us because
every now and then when I talk about
representation for LGBTQ there are
people who kind of shake their finger at
me and say don't demand representation
go out and do it yourself now we're
trying we would like to but our
opportunities aren't presented to us and
most of us don't have the resources to
make these things on our own so that I
think is where I'm going to end this
particular ramble I think I actually
kept much calmer than I expected to
because when I first read and heard
about this I had some errands to run and
I was screaming in my car so for how
upset I actually am by this I think I
kept it fairly calm what are your
thoughts on this casting and the
response from Scarlett Johansson's
representative whatever your thoughts
are please be respectful to the people
involved to me no personal attacks
please because I will delete comments
but short of that whatever your thoughts
are whether you agree with me or not
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you can support me on
patreon to try and
make this bigger and better you can
follow me on Twitter I have another
youtube channel devoted more
specifically to my gender fluidity I'll
link to that below links for all this
stuff and even more will be down in the
description so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]